you
here we go Horowitz arena 56 players
let's go with d4 and get some quick
moves in here alright I'm fine with that
mm-hm let's put pressure on the night
let's get castled building the center
maybe chop off the center get to this
open file or half open file that's
probably not a good move what I did but
I'll give it a shot
maybe Knight here next g5 might have
been a good move I like my fish hunk and
I'm gonna kick their night away and then
it's difficult to get that push in
actually take like this let's see hmm
it's come back over here clean before
hmm alright let's uh I want to get rid
of their knight actually they're giving
me a difficult time with that
okay I'm dropping this pawn I'm dropping
a lot of stuff oh I think I'm gonna get
mated this is gonna be painful
this is gonna be very painful oh that's
a very very painful Oh
smothered mate with the pawn involved
ouch that Knight got to be too much I
probably should have taken him out when
he was on d6 okay let's see if we could
rebound playing against the Scandinavian
okay let's let's [ __ ] with the bishop
play Knight to f6 or Knight to f3 okay
d4 d5 okay
I got some space castle rook to e1 okay
let's keep that pawn around
I think it's awkward for them I get
their Bishop out now Bishop f4 Bishop to
b5 let's give this check right now
probably this no matter what
and then here not so fast
take with the rook or just pile up on
that pond okay that is some material
there okay so this is winning the farm
right here that's a check it should be
made into one right here is made
okay back determined return to
tournament - all right
plenty of time left in this one if
there's a game to lose it's the first
one that way it isn't running it's not
ruining any streak so let's see if we
could back and get back on the horse
here what a what a line for chess huh
back on the horse alright John Madden I
have a feeling he's gonna put his Queen
on c2 let's see if I'm right
okay you got this Center in mmm let's
stop b4 first there right stop a knight
pivot on g5 I guess here let's open up
the position play that move maybe
playing this next all right if that
Knight moves Knight d4 I'll wait for the
night to move maybe night here stuff
yeah let's do this and then play g6 top
the knife from getting to f5 let's do
this right now
um let's defend maybe b5 you know let's
go with b5 hit at their b2 pond 90
take towards the center hmm that's
tricky I'm dropping my a pond the night
is maybe a bit stranded okay I'll keep
high the open file not quite sure what
that does fish of a two let's come back
mmm getting into a mouse slipper those
are tough they resigned back to
determine I thought for a second they
might have offered a take back but not
the case okay
c5 don't let's get a king-sized fiend
kiddo get d5 in dropping a pond or am i
mmm let's take here that's what check
its castle that is defended Bishop to d7
let's not drop that pond it's gonna be
more Tempe gained against my queen let's
get out of the way
Knight here oh they giving me their dark
square Bishop Knight d5 let's go here
hopefully my knight could be annoying
not quite sure what that's doing
stopping g5 stuff let's get b4 in they
have a huge time edge huge I can win
this fun take the knight let's do that
actually then okay we're exchanging
stuff I like this but the time is a big
big issue very big okay let's do some
dancing a little bit
Oh grab this pond why don't you grab
that fun
you don't like freak material deal man
that's not the way to win if you don't
like free material you're gonna have a
tough day very tough day okay how about
I push my pond hmm let's drop them first
okay let's hunt this guy down let's
start with this they're offering me a
draw I want to draw I'm gonna try to win
this one okay this makes it much easier
got a run like the wind blow is for scum
style get ready run like the wind blows
go fast hunt this pond down give me
finally back to tournament man the
Ferrari is here oh man is he
Wow 24 he was a late joiner
he's like I'll I'm not gonna enter right
away just after the tournament starts
I'll pop in somebody's gotta knock that
guy out 24 points my goodness walk out
okay let's get c-4 in 93 Bishop e2
Castle what a mountain to climb 24
points Wow
iPhone is that moving why aren't they
moving just then a 3 and B 4 I guess
they're still not moving
spending more time than me I'm uh I'm
not really so fast
okay I'm winning some material no ah
they could do an in-betweener
and take my queen I get to their back
rank I definitely get to their back rank
it's got to be uncomfortable no I love
how they got out the pin not sure
that's doing alright let's get back here
I still have another rook they can't
move their Bishop with check just make
sure of that okay so I guess we're gonna
play this position where I there's some
structural defect I don't know if it's
really anything it could take advantage
of but I'll give it a shot it's around a
check and I win material with that and
am I going to get trapped maybe let's do
this first
kick the night yeah I'm gonna get
trapped but fortunately no I don't have
that I'm in trouble I'm in big trouble I
got to take another pawn down maybe not
so easy for them to win let's do this
first and yeah okay this is completely
lost well they have to time will they
have the time oh they did have the time
there but should have taken okay now
this is maybe winning for me I got him
on the clock but lucky lucky lucky okay
28 13 13 he is truth he's berserk nearly
every game hmm three three there's only
three games that he didn't preserve for
games berserk four games one Hovick all
right let's let's maybe play a little
bit crazy yeah III is crazy isn't it
III is crazy Queeny to e4 let's open up
the center I'm gonna play e5 we're gonna
see that f6 Queen here Bishop g5 should
be seven Bishop e7 Queen g3 rook d1 do
they really mean to do that
mmm okay it's not me but their King is
probably not so comfortable ooh I almost
thought my queen was trapped there okay
let's go here let's not trade Queens
well let's still not trade Queens I have
h2 covered thankfully stop it I don't
want a queen trade enough of that what's
that even doing okay
get my Bishop on e4 the bishop on f6 is
very very good don't like that dropped
upon maybe we get there be fun if their
bishop moves maybe I could get it f7 one
day um your I guess like my bishops
pinned probably get out of that huh
how's the clock here I guess take on uh
let's just stop neh to stuff here and
yeah lacking a plan here maybe take and
then Bishop c6 stuff well it's not
really working I'm just playing for time
here let's just do something quick
anything don't lose on time
I'm almost losing on time I'm almost
getting made it somehow I was ugly
another ugly 137 you kidding me oh my
goodness how do you catch somebody who
has 37
that is ridiculous you need to slow down
I think I say that every time he's in
one of these tournaments you need to
slow down okay let's go Bishop here and
then III let's get some development in
stop the pin okay they're not deploying
their LightSquared bishop it's Castle
Knight here and then F
take I get the F file Knight d5 I avoid
the knight exchange I drop d5 is b5 as
well I didn't see it let's come back
here night before is probably good let's
secure my bishop now that they didn't
play that let's kick their Knight
and again just so c5 isn't in there and
let's play against their King side okay
there shouldn't be any breaks over here
on the Kings side let's pile up on the
up on let's get into these squares take
here no matter what and there should be
mate right around the corner no mmm
let's go here made on g7 soon we're
gonna see that's me so help me they're
in a tough spot there 37 2017 yeah I
mean even if I uh even if I get paired
up with them I think I could get paired
up with them like three times win all
three highly unlikely but yeah it's it's
that that much of a climb here I gotta
get him back here that's mother this is
the smothered mate guy is that what I
should come from now on the smothered
mate guy just to just to remind everyone
of that time that I got beat with the
smothered mate let's not let that happen
again
alright let's play here secure the e5
square put pressure on the V pond hey
let's sacrifice something h2 let's do it
let's go here sneakiness h2 bishop here
on Bishop f4
hmm okay take here it is upon Queen here
is probably good
yeah income and queen there okay how am
i completing development is a question I
have and I don't have I don't have a
good answer to that I don't think you
had a run got a crawl up into a ball
maybe f5 or f6 hmm I got to hold my dark
squares my eight pound could fall at any
moment like right now are my C pawn
actually oh boy let's come back over
here my king's still in the middle
alright let's let's run this is uh this
is definitely losing I'm crawling up
into a ball let's push this pawn
centralize my queen maybe King e7 he's a
fighting piece queen trade g4 probably
here King here I don't have any time
okay this is actually probably winning
here but I do not have any time no time
fortunately no time I got out for a draw
came here not working they're probably
going to dance some more
Oh barely
oh man I got lucky with the draw there
ah man
41 22 21 13 minutes remain so behind on
the clock
ah okay less than less than 13 minutes
left
let's try c5 okay Queen c7 let's do this
first meet d4 with the capture and then
d5 I guess
then let's play this first and get that
advance in huh
okay okay probably wasn't the greatest
move in the world their work to be eight
and let's stop the g5 pivot get my
knight in to c4 Knight b6 into c4 he
could be kicked but that we can see
three all right I'll go for this get my
bishop on b5 now he was the worst piece
now he's becoming a monster I get the
exchange and let's just do this for
starters stop sacrifices on h6 fine with
that
um Queen trade the Queen again get my
Queen on e4 that's exactly where she
wants to be Queen back home put the
bishop in a pin I guess here I want to
keep my Queen active here rook to the
seventh okay push this pawn
I guess we're gonna cash out a little
bit okay
um yeah I'm just dropping that pun okay
they didn't take it let's pin this night
okay okay I got to go faster I gotta
grab that pun mm-hmm oh man I got to get
rid of their pawns or do I have time to
get this oh my goodness barely one point
for this is awful Oh lucky lucky lucky
I'm like yeah maybe I could just get all
their pawns and hope for a silly little
draw cuz they don't material to me Oh
can I somehow leave to me hmm
okay what can you do man what can you do
just got to move fast the speed is
lacking though I'm down in every game
timewise I guess here drop a pawn right
if you don't know what to do drop your
deep on he's terrible all right you
don't need him for anything I made him
think though now let's take here okay
let's hit there see to fajn kick their
night away Knight takes pawn takes he
has to find a new home and I get the
epon and now I'm up up I now I'm up upon
amazingly all right let's hit their
queen
their queen again no all right let's
hang on to this pawn pawn push my Queens
hit remember that it's important all
right let's push here no let's take and
let's get
he's just too much of a pest he really
is
I gotta watch out for f7 it's a
dangerous square a very dangerous square
they're down on time I like seeing that
what about a night here put a knight in
the center why don't you all right let's
take here push my opponent let's come
back stay coordinated and save a night
push through all right they're gonna
give up their Bishop got the rook and
this guy could drop f7 now you get that
check and they're down on time back to
tournament 59 check that 64 he just
finished I think we're getting paired up
8 minutes 3 million 64 28 here he is no
I don't even know how to start I don't
even know how to start against him my
goodness I feel like I have to give
checkmate because the clock it's just
never gonna happen you're not gonna be
faster than the Ferrari it's just how it
is
it really it is let's come back here f2
was sensitive Queen b6 stuff f2 is still
sensitive to crawl up into a ball now
it's already a terrible sign all right
let's get stopped that night from a
pivoting on e4 he's just gonna be too
good let's get to the d4 square if I can
move my knight to b3 first it's very
important I do that it's very important
you get your Knight to b3 before you
could get into d4 now we're gonna get
here and maybe pile up on what exactly
I'm not quite sure I'm gonna do a pawn
push let's go here I'm not quite sure
about it okay stop Knight c4 here I
guess all right let's take with the pawn
in the night here that fish up here
yeah let's get out of the line of fire
Queen trade let's come back let's go
here now hitting the rook and the bishop
um I got the exchange but it's never
really uh I don't know
can't feel confident really I'm into a
pin
okay I could push this pawn soon could
have taken this pawn actually mmm ready
for maid on f2 huh
that was close to happening they're
gonna start flying take that pawn I
thought at least in-betweener it's a
very important in-betweener okay this is
winning but I do not have any time all
right push still I'm gonna throw some
checks in oh that was terrible okay
yeah and now I'm in big trouble I'm
walking into skewers and stuff oh I'm
down on time oh that was awful he kicked
it into a higher gear as usual 6868 wrap
your head around that number please 68
my goodness five and change Wow okay
let's break pins
it's Castle get to the beef I'll grab a
tempo against this guy and it's also
useful for a flight square let's push
these guys I guess this isn't a good
structure these six is probably good
Queen trade no rook trade I mean secure
d4 mmm don't really want to do that
crawling into a ball if their Knight
moves like play here not sure what that
moves doing okay let's get here watch
over c4 um-hmm let's play against their
dark squares can i bishop on h6 oh I
thought I was actually gonna damage
their pawn structure not the case ninth
c4 know maybe Bishop to a6 was better or
is their night going hmm
okay let's do this grab a pawn let's go
here rook to d8 right okay trade I'm
fine with that
let's come all the way back and that
here is probably good
look here now a knight here I could go
back one move sooner it would have been
very awkward Knight a5 I have to stop
knight b3 a knight is in a strong spot
okay officer collar bishops I just want
to do this to clear my Bishop out of the
way
alright let's hang on to him that's all
I have office of colors it's a it's a
losing uh well it's it's a draw I think
but objectively yeah its objective draw
about time it's a different story here
just run here be sneaky I'm gonna lose
on time they're playing very fast okay
finally they lost on time 77 three
minutes and change let's try the Cairo
with Knight f6 let's pin the night
alright that is weakening let's get my
knight in to d5 soon secure my bishop
position first a4 and then Queen to a5
on 94 I'm not quite sure what I'll do
because of d6 let's go here first let's
take that guy ooh this is a beautiful
square for my night now
okay this is a very very good position
let's go here okay this is an excellent
structure take with the pawn and then
target there beep on let's go here first
I guess Bishop g5 and now they're doing
that rook here on Bishop c3 Bishop takes
pawn as a threat okay they didn't see
that I guess this is winning but the
clock I just never feel confident
clockwise never okay if they hunt down
my King I have this here so the rook is
restricted then let's stop there King I
could have also taken their pawn I have
a time edge and we're looking good on
the clock so that's nice let's look to
play here and get behind the pawn let's
just go here first defend some stuff and
then push through okay I should have
this one I should have this one keep on
pushing here and anything more okay they
resigned back determine 82 39 35 32
where am i 30 yokes yeah I need to
berserk and yeah it's not even going to
be helpful this game won't even finish
okay so we're just gonna play this for
now it's not going to count for the
tournament but let's still try to get
the W rookie one useful move for a
flight square stuff I guess Queen to d2
let's actually grab some space over here
Queen d2 maybe b4 I don't know
we can the d5 square maybe I could play
for that
let's take here first and then here and
then b5 okay I get this move in but I am
down upon and my nights gonna be
dislodged very soon isn't he
I might be b5 twice though another rook
yeah let's come over here defend that I
could also reinforce it with c4 light
squares night here soon I imagined
okay pawn push hmm
soon I probably have to play g3 yeah g3
soon yeah let's do that right now
a my knight in to e4 where he hits
everything I feel like I don't want to
even give him up okay I will take that
and defend over here these squares Oh
rook takes Bishop ah I guess I should
have taken that guy huh okay now take
them okay let's get my queen active
Queen f6 maybe let's go here Queen f6 on
night here we can one oh there's a nice
fork right here let's do this see how it
turns out turned out pretty good and I
get a queen back okay get the night they
resign
back to tournament it is complete yo you
need to slow down win rate 100% berserk
win rate 50
yikes look at how many games that's
ridiculous 20 final standings 86 where
we at 86 40 39 33 32 32 32 30
how many games did I heaven not enough 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 too little we had
20 wow what a fantastic result that is
again 86 40 39 top three now let's see
everyone else who took part in this make
sure it's showing up here here we go
there's page two oh three four five here
are all the players all 84 of you all
right to the 84 of you GG's all alright
that was a fantastic result my goodness
I don't think I've seen a result like
that
not in any of the tournaments that I've
posted to the YouTube channel that is 20
games is a lot to get in wha-wha
you